[Music]
flavor is such a keynote to memory it's
one of our most Primal instincts we can
play games with flavors that people
don't understand we want to create
something which brings back a memory
because candy and flavors themselves are
not the whole story we're just giving
notes and your brain fills in what's in
between you're using your imagination to
complete the picture here oh and the
picture happens to be one of
Flavor
here at lofty Pursuits we make hard
candy not bubble gum but we're still
going to make a full meal in hard candy
we're going to have blueberry pie sweet
corn apple cider and ham yeah ham
because you need a full meal today I'm
working with iie and Franchesca we're
going to make round drops of candy and
the nice thing about the round drops is
they dissolve evenly in your mouth so
it's going to give an even flavor
profile